that they were not going to follow
through on these agreements what else
can you say here the first people in the
government publicly stated that
what else can you expect do you expect
to continue us watching people abusing
the government abusing
uh
uh citizens on these territories it's
impossible to do that you see yourself
what is happening there how can you just
watch us
our colleagues
when we spoke to them
european colleagues used to say the same
thing yes you have to follow this
agreement you have to follow the
agreement but they did couldn't
force the kiev government to follow
through on the agreement so we had to
make that decision
so in this respect yes minsk agreements
what
that means we have recognized all
fundamental
documents and their constitution
and constitution
determines the borders
while they were
part of ukraine but we're counting on
on
resolution of all these
differences
um
that these differences will be sorted
out before between government and uh
lugansk advanced regions
but
for the moment we understand that this
is probably impossible
in this current situation
but we're hoping for this to happen in
the future
as for using military force abroad
of course
we signed an agreement yesterday
and in these agreements
with donetsk and lugansk
relevant points which state that
we are going to continue
we will provide uh all
type of assistance including military
assistance if there is a conflict of
course
if it's necessary
we will
we will follow through on the
obligations that we undertook
the sovereignty of these two republics
and our decision
and they are not happy with our decision
sir what did you say
i'm saying that
these
republics are not recognized by kiev
and they're not happy with our decision
either
after what happened
today and yesterday do you see any
prospects for rehabilitating the
relationships between kiev and moscow
what should moscow do and what should
kiev do
in this regard we did discuss these
questions
in our negotiations with our european
partners and also with americans
i think it did not it was not said
publicly but i'll say this
naturally
the question is
what
do both parties have to do
from cave aside from our side so that we
could
regulate this issue
in the long-term historic perspective so
we could uh coexist friendly without any
military conflicts
that needs to be done is to recognize
the will
of the people in sevastopol in and in
crimea
and i would like to emphasize
how is this will of people worse than
the will of people of kosovo
so
in kosovo it was a formal decision here
it was done through a referendum
nobody could force people
um on the
you know barrels to come and vote they
just came voluntarily and they voted and
you have to respect that decision
those
those who consider themselves to be
democratic countries they have to
recognize this fact this is number one
second
so we are saying this publicly
and this is uh
one of the questions of
around which we have disagreements with
washington and nato we are categorically
against
ukraine joining nato because this is a
threat to us
and i've mentioned that many times
and in this relation
of course our position is based on
what many people say
including people in the western capitals
that the best resolution of this
issue would be
so that our colleagues in the
west do not lose their face
the best thing to do would be for
kiev authorities
not to to make a decision not to join
nato and become neutral
that's number two
number three unfortunately this is no
longer current
i always said that
we needed to resolve donbass issue
through
peaceful negotiations
and through implementation of minsk
agreements and fourth is the most
important thing
everything that's been
said before all of that can be turned
upside down if
our so-called partners
continue to pump
cave authorities with modern types of
weapons
so the most important point
is
is a certain degree of demilitarization
of current ukraine
because this is
the only
factor that you can objectively control
and that you can
that you can react to and you can
monitor
otherwise all other points can be turned
around
turned around
how it's been done by the current head
of ukraine
[Music]
where they're trying to persecute the
former leader of ukraine
through
criminal means and uh or through means
of criminal law and so on
so the same thing can be done to any
other agreements that i just mentioned
now
and then
person can just flee to washington
berlin or paris
and we would just stay here with these
issues this is not acceptable
this is not acceptable
especially after
the current uh leadership of ukraine
announced their nuclear ambitions
yesterday in your address to
russians you mentioned
words
ukraine might have ukraine uh nuclear
weapons again
is it just his words or do we have an
actual threat that near our borders in
ukraine there'll be nuclear weapons i
just mentioned this now
we understand
that these words were addressed to us
and i would like to say that yes we
heard them
ukraine since soviet times
had uh
quite an extensive
nuclear competences they've got several
nuclear units and their nuclear industry
is well developed they've got schools
they've got everything
in order
to
much quicker resolve
this issue
compared to other countries where
they're trying to build it from the
ground i'm not going to mention those
you you're familiar with these
situations
there's only one thing lacking
enrichment system but it's just a
technical question
for ukraine
this is not an unresolvable
issue as for
and that's about 110 kilometer range
[Music]
what is the threat to us
that even the appearance of tactical
nuclear weapons for us
means strategic threat
this is something that we have to take
into account
because
110 kilometers can be increased to 300
to 500 kilometers
and then moscow will be
within the
the reach of these rockets for us this
is a strategic threat and this is how we
perceived it and of course
in a very serious way we have to treat
this and we will treat this in this way
uh
what is your opinion do you think
that in the modern world is it possible
to
resolve things through
through force and be on the
side of good
and the second question is technical
questions
in your opinion
how fast
can military
go
to the administrative
uh borders or to the front line
first of all i'd like to say
the
military force
will go there straight up after our
the course of events it will be
dependent on the situation
on the ground
why do you think that
good
should always be powerless i do not
think so
i think that
good
presumes the ability to defend yourself